jean de gliniasty merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors on vient
de voir l'instant cette zone le haut
karabagh et depuis des années l'objet de
tensions entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan
mais pourquoi la situation a dégénéré le
week-end dernier
bah je crois que il y aura de nombreux
éclats de ce genre puisque la situation
le statu quo est insupportable pour les
azerbaïdjanais puisque en gros l'arménie
occupe un peu moins de 20% du territoire
azerbaïdjanais et le camp plus la
légitimité du président aliev dès le
début de la dynastie aliev dès son
installation dans les années 90 et la
récupération du haut karabagh donc tant
qu'il n'y aura pas de solution négociée
eh bien nous aurons des incidents de ce
genre qui peuvent dégénérer en guerre
bien entendu à chaque fois alors la
russie appelle à un cessez le feu
immédiat d'autres pays en font de même
qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce que peut
craindre la communauté internationale
aujourd'hui que ce conflit déstabilise
finalement le caucase du sud
alors c'est un des rares cas où le
groupe chargé de faire de trop une
solution comporte à la fois les
etats-unis la russie et la france donc
on peut penser qu'il y aura une
convergence des efforts internationaux
pour assurer une médiation mais ça c'est
une médiation pour un cessez-le-feu
la question qui se pose c'est vraiment
de trouver une solution durable
alors le groupe de minsk etats-unis
france russie avait proposé à madrid en
une solution qui prévoyait un référendum
l'autodétermination des cas rabat 6 qui
prévoyait la restitution des territoires
propre mazars vad jeannet qui entoure le
haut karabakh et qu'il prévoyait la
sécurité du corridor de
chine qui rejoint le haut karabakh et
l'arménie malheureusement cette solution
qui était une solution de bon sens
d'ailleurs n'a pas été acceptée ni par
l'arménie ni par l'azerbaïdjan et
pourquoi ça bloque ou temps et ça bloque
toujours aujourd'hui
bah ça bloque parce que quel pays
accepterait d'avoir quasiment 20% son
territoire occupé et pas seulement
d'ailleurs les territoires la population
arménie arménienne est par ailleurs
comme vous l'avez très bien notées dans
votre rappel des dates importantes
ça fait depuis la république de
transcaucasie les comment dirais-je les
caravanes chine ne souhaitait pas
rentrer être inclus dans l'azerbaïdjan
et d'ailleurs gorbatchev et de bureau
politique en 1988 ont refusé et une
énième demande du haut karabakh d'être
attaché à l'arménie donc c'est un
problème qu'il devra nécessairement être
réglé par l'établissement d'un régime
très particulier de dieu haut karabakh
que le haut karabakh n'a pu obtenir que
par la force dans les années 90 alors il
y a également la turquie qui soutient
fermement l'azerbaïdjan est ce que ce
soutien complique aussi un peu plus la
donne pour la communauté internationale
oui c'est évident c'est évident parce
que la russie a maintenu jusqu'à présent
une position de neutralité
il ya ce qu'on appelle la doctrine
primakov qui disait que en gros la
russie était lié par un accord de
défense au sein de l'hôtel de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective à l'arménie mais ça ne
concernait que le territoire arménien ça
ne concernait pas le haut karabakh donc
la rue 6
si verrez comme légitime pour jouer un
rôle particulier pour obtenir un cessez
le feu ce qu'elle a fait la fête tout le
temps elle l'a fait en 94 elle l'a fait
en 2016 elle leur fait la ferme de début
2009 un don qu'elle est un partenaire
important pour la paix mais la russie
est aussi pourvoyeuse d'armes aux uns
comme aux autres
donc ça peut lui donner d'ailleurs
disons une autorité supplémentaires pour
la turquie c'est un peu de thym peu
différent la turquie disons
l'azerbaïdjan est un pays de langue sur
site en dehors du russe que beaucoup de
gens parlent donc elle est relativement
proche de la turquie
et on sait que vers doan a une politique
que certains qualifient de néo ottomane
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait exacts mais
en tout cas une politique d' influence
dans les pays d'asie centrale qui parle
qui parle le turc ou des langues proches
du turc
alors pour conclure en quelques mots une
réunion d'urgence à huis clos du conseil
de sécurité de l'onu doit avoir lieu
dans un peu plus d'une heure maintenant
qu'est-ce qui peut en ressortir
selon vous ben je crois que l'unanimité
sera plus facile à obtenir puisque comme
je le disais les états unis et les
russes sont parties prenantes et les
français donc que mais une unanimité en
fait concrètement ça veut dire que la
russie dans son travail de médiation
appuyez sur le groupe de minsk aura le
soutien et la légitimité d'un accord du
conseil de sécurité pour essayer
d'obtenir un accord qui à ce stade ne
sera qu'un accord de cessez-le-feu une
fois de plus merci beaucoup
jean de gliniasty pour votre éclairage
je rappelle que vous êtes directeur de
recherche à l'institut de relations
internationales et stratégiques